ça a commencé en classe de cinquième vos
camarades de classe vous désigne très
vite comme la personne de qui il faut se
moquer c'est ça oui surtout sur le
physique comment ça a commencé on me
disait boboul je te pousse sur roule on
m'insultait de salles grosse de baleines
d'abord c'était surtout des insultes sur
le physique et c'était un nouveau
collège dans lequel vous alliez ou c'est
non d'accord parce qu'on 6e c'était
plutôt tranquille et 105e que ça ça
s'est vraiment dégradée déclaré oui et
au fil des années ça c'est encore
empirer alors pourquoi tu étais là si tu
avais dit que tu avais des copines quand
même j'avais une amie sur quoi mais
ben elle est partie du côté des
harceleuse away ac s'est fait influencer
et en fait elle t'a laissé tomber dans
coiffure qu'au départ en cas de 5e que
tu arrives tu as ta copine tu te fais
vraiment voilà harceler tous les jours
et là tu vois en plus que ta copine part
du côté des dérouleurs oui c'est
exactement ça c'était plutôt des filles
ou des garçons et des filles les filles
que des filles ont fait et qu'est ce qui
te faisait subir
comme je le dis aux débats au départ
c'était juste des insultes sur le
physique d'accord et au fil du temps ça
empire et ça allait du suicide toi
c'était toujours des insultes sur le
physique et après on me menace et c'est
venu sur les réseaux
manas et de quelle manière on te disait
quoi on me disait on va te frapper même
qu'un jour on m'a donné rendez vous
derrière le collège pour me frapper pour
me filmer et je suis allé leur apporter
un surveillant et le surveillant madiba
c'est normal qu'elles soient énervés
parce que t'es pas venu au rendez vous
donc en fait il aurait fallu que je me
fasse frapper pour que les arts se
laissera pas énervé que je sois pas venu
assure parce que quelqu'un s'est passé
ce rendez vous il vous en dire ouais
mais on vous en dit pourquoi était ce
rendez vous à la base non c'était en
classe on m'a dit ouais bah les
harceleuse avait le palais fille à
veulent te frappées et insultées et au
final
belmont pas dit d'elle même on me l'a
dit de bouche à l'eau à oreille ça
correspond bien sûr tu as peut être au
rendez vous oui et que ce qui s'est
passé derrière
on m'a pas prise au sérieux et surtout
le bal surveillants je m'en souviendrai
toujours je pense qu'ils qui m'a dit ça
c'est pas du tout la réaction à avoir
face à quelqu'un qui a peur de se faire
frapper insulté alors justement on va
continuer le récit de l'insee et de
s'est littéralement monsieur ministre ça
c'est des témoignages qu'on entend assez
souvent alors on veut pas remettre en
cause bien sûr le travail des
surveillants des professeurs mais c'est
vrai que parfois la réponse est un petit
peu faible par rapport à la à la force
du harcèlement à la force de de la
déléguée de la détresse de 2,2 voilà de
l'insee par exemple est ce
qu'aujourd'hui on peut améliorer ça oui
bien sûr on sait bien que ça se passe
pas de la même façon d'un endroit à
l'autre ça dépend beaucoup la voie de la
sensibilité puis de la formation des uns
et des autres donc c'est pour ça qu'on a
commencé d'abord à systématiser la la
formation des futurs professeurs et des
futurs surveillants aussi ce qu'on
appelle les cpe les conseillers
principaux d'éducation qui supervise les
surveillants désormais les nouveaux si
je puis dire sont formés aux enjeux du
harcèlement et de la prévention du
harcèlement et donc par exemple mieux
accueillir une parole comme celle là
pour répondre quelque chose de pertinent
et surtout qui est une suite
ensuite on a maintenant la formation
continue de ceux qui sont actuellement
en poste et c'est le programme qu'on
appelle le programme phare qui a
vocation à se déployer toute cette année
c'est à dire qu'il ya d'ici à la fin de
l'année scolaire 100 % des
établissements seront rentrés dans le
programme phare qui comporte la
formation de l'équipe de professeurs et
de et de cpe pour justement mieux réagir
et être mieux mieux adaptée c'est pas
facile c'est facile pour personne
d'ailleurs un sujet comme ça et c'est
donc normal qu'il faille un peu de
formation de sensibilisation d'outils
pour y arriver et c'est ce que nous
déployons maintenant l'insee et céline
quand vous entendez ministre vous vous
dites quoi personne formée au
harcèlement dans les établissements
scolaires parce que sinon ils sont
répartis mode pertinemment comment
réagir moi on m'a pas prise au sérieux
et même d'ailleurs en dehors du collège
que ce soit les les gendarmes on a
refusé notre dernière plainte est non on
m'a pas prise au sérieuse et on m'a on
m'a pas cru la cpe tu disais que science
et polaire c'est le rectorat où
l'académie elle risquait sa place ça
c'est souvent ce qu'on entend mais
monsieur le ministre on entend souvent
il ya aussi un système paire de
chaussures d'éducation qui est compliqué
pour les lycées pour les collègues c'est
ce système de notation et souvent on
entend par voilà des ddd proue des
directeurs de lycée et directeur de deux
collèges dire qu'ils n'ont pas trop
ébruiter la faire parce que sinon on va
avoir une mauvaise note et on va être
mal notés et c'est très mauvais pour la
réputation du collège et les thalys du
lycée et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui c'est
à chaque fois ce que j'entends quand
j'ai des témoignages sur le plateau
comment on peut répondre à ça est ce que
on peut changer ce système ou pas c'est
vrai que ça a pu exister ça peut encore
exister ce que vous dites là je la
reconnais volontiers ont nommé j'ai été
très clair depuis quatre ans jeudi les
établissements ne sont pas évalués sur
le nombre de signalements qu'ils font
c'est le contraire même c'est si quelque
chose a eu lieu et qui n'est pas signalé
que là il ya un problème on peur alors
les chefs d'établissement parce que on
l'entend souvent sabords et max à face
de bruit j'ai eu je vous dis je suis un
autre cas encore d'un ami voilà jeudi à
ccc
saku voilà qui est un grand joueur de
foot qui m'a appelé un jour qui m'a dit
voilà ma fille a subi dans son à l'école
des dvd des remarques très raciste d
elle a été vraiment très touchés il me
dit je suis allé voir l'établissement et
ils m'ont dit non non monsieur sakho
n'en parle pas parce qu'on veut pas trop
que ça sache que ça sorte c'est vrai que
pour nous pour la réputation c'est pas
beau
il ya deux sujets liés à la réputation
dans le territoire où on se trouve et
puis il ya la relation avec
l'institution donc sur la relation avec
l'institution j'ai vraiment été je suis
très clair j'en profite pour dire très
publiquement ici il faut être très clair
pour tout le monde les établissements ne
sont pas évalués au nombre de deux
signalements qu'il faut au contraire on
est très attentif désormais à ça ils
sont même évalué désormais au sur le bon
climat scolaire ce que je dis vient de
commencer ça fait deux ans que ça par
exemple climat scolaire et nuit donc ça
ça peut être considéré comme un mauvais
climat si on voit qui est officiellement
et c'est comme ça peut baisser la masse
et sans toutefois servir que un
établissement depuis deux ans ça a
commencé tous les établissements ne sont
pas encore passés dans cette logique
mais ça signifie qu'un établissement
doit d'abord s'auto-évaluer c'est à dire
que l'équipe doit regarder ce me
discuter pour voir où en est le climat
scolaire et puis une fois qu'ils ont
fait cette auto évaluation et des
équipes qui arrivent pour faire
l'évaluation et regardez ce que disent
les acteurs par exemple les parents
d'élèves les professeurs l'ensemble des
acteurs sur ce qui selon leurs points
forts et leurs points faibles en matière
de climat scolaire sachant que comme je
le disais en commençant il s'agit pas
seulement de regarder s'il ya pas de
harcèlement mais aussi de voir s'il ya
du bon climat scolaire c'est-à-dire
escales de l'engagement des élèves dans
des causes d'intérêt général est ce
qu'on est heureux de vivre tout
simplement dans cet établissement et
c'est évidemment l'intérêt de tous
d'arriver à ce arrêt à commencer par les
par les chefs d'établissement n'oublions
pas qu'ils ont un métier difficile ils
ont surtout les jours des sollicitations
de tous ordres et donc c'est aussi
normal parfois ils essayent tout
simplement de régler le problème en
considérant que c'est qu'ils vont y
arriver sans avoir besoin forcément de
le signaler alors les quand c'est
suffisamment grave il faut évidemment le
signalé l'insee pas rien n'a été pas
heureuse dans son dans son collège donc
très vite les moqueries vont devenir des
injures et même des coups alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est cool
qualité de l'eau de la bascule alors en
particulier je me suis battu avec l'une
d'entre elles
j'étais dehors et au final c'est pour ça
que j'ai arrêté de sortir dehors dans
mon village parce que donc elle
maintenant ça continue elle était toute
seule non il y avait des amis à elle
mais c'est pas des personnes que je
pourrai considérer comme des harceleurs
d'accord et donc elle était là elle elle
a commencé atteint sulte et ses saillies
à m'insulter je me laissais pas faire au
final parce que j'en avais marre
d'accord et on s'est battu et après moi
je suis parti et elle est partie en
pleurant donc je pense qu'elle est
sûrement à les rapporter à sa mère
d'ailleurs sa mère aussi elle la
défendez et d'ailleurs c'est comme ça
pour les trois harceleuse les parents
aussi sont mis à m'insulter ah oui quand
je vais chercher mes soeurs à la
primaire les parents m'insulte en
sortant du collège il y avait la mamie
de l'une d'entre elle qui m'a insulté de
kaunas et m'a fait des deux donneurs
donc au final même là je n'étais pas
tranquille et je me suis là on est allé
au collège la boule au ventre à redon
tel au collège la boule au ventre tous
les jours tu es t elle pas envie d'y
aller oui tu disais quoi ta maman je
disais rien c'est vrai c'est vous disais
rien sinon ça vous étiez pas au courant
de tout ça non au départ non pas du tout
vous voyez que lindsay n'était pas bien
ou pas du tout oui oui mais on met ça
sur le dos de l'adolescence c'est ça et
c'est toujours pareil comment vous avez
appris qu'elles vivent elles ont fait un
collage son frère qui s'est rendu compte
de ce que son petit frère ou son grand
frère en grand frère accord si rendu
compte de scarifications il était dans
le même non non et non il était déjà au
lycée à cordes et donc il s'est rendu
compte de scarification oui mais mettez
des manches longues
moins élevé sa manche et il a vu et que
s'il m'a dit vas voir quelque chose qui
va passer scarifié et puis voilà c'est
là qu'elle a commencé à en parler quoi
et donc là vous a été la voir et l'insee
vote commencent à tous vous raconte non
pas tout non vous avez quoi vous est
versé au fur à mesure on à dire quoi
vous avez agi comme en ce moment là vous
avez été voir l'établissement où vous
avez été par les parents des parents des
harceleurs non non l'établissement tout
de suite non j'avais été voir qui le
chef d'établissement principales cibles
et qu'est-ce qui vous ont dit j'ai été
mise à la porte d'accord pour voir que
pour eux c'est des histoires de gosse
d'accord c'était il avait fait le
nécessaire quand il y avait eu des
soucis kevin siècle est venu les voir
c'était quoi le nécessaire ben les
convoquer tous les trois ans le plus une
scène est convoqué puis recadrer quoi et
ça n'a pas bougé derrière et pire
d'ailleurs même mais ses pieds voilà et
donc on vous a mis à la porte donc vous
aviez rendez-vous vous avez dit pourquoi
vous aviez rendez vous c'est aller
direct et pourront découvrir les rouges
et donc vous arrivez dans le bureau du
principal et du cpe et vous voilà enfin
que je raconte ce qui se passe et je
veux des explications aux cycles des
automatiques mans dont vous dise et on
sait régler l'affairé avec les façons
ils ont fait le nécessaire et que
tout est réglé et que de toute façon ils
peuvent pas faire plus que ça
ils peuvent pas surveiller tous nos
plats court donc la voix claire vous
revenez à la maison vous dites quoi
l'insee
benz et je lui dis des quelque chose tu
me le dis d'accord est en fait il est
arrivé à tous les jours tous les jours
me retrouver au collège ah oui il n'est
pas un jour il n'est pas un problème
vous faisait que vous avez été devant
les parents des arts se saouler
harceleuse elle-même alors les parents
non d'accord mais là j'en ai entendu
parler qu'on m'a dit on m'a dit que ça
servait à rien de toute façon d'accord
et receveuse non parce que d'abord j'ai
fait confiance à l'établissement est
ensuite m'a fait confiance à la justice
aux siens automatiquement puisque a eu
dépôt de pain que tout
par contre au bout de deux ans quand
même son père qui était qui était déjà
mourant est allé la chercher à l'école
et
devant l'établissement il a engueulé
l'une d'elles il a dit la première que
je vois gelant gueule en espérant que ça
s'arrête ou kibala porté plainte
parce qu'elle a été traumatisée et il
s'est retrouvé
quatre mois avant son décès devant le
tribunal juge dans un tribunal
et on a dû et on a dû payer des dommages
et intérêts et frais d'avocats et il
était décidé que je payais encore si
dommages et intérêts
donc là l'insee tu te dis a pas de
solution bon bah c'est exactement ce que
je me suis dit parce qu'au collège au
final on ne prenait pas au sérieux et
même la justice ne faisait rien ils ont
fini par ne plus prendre nos dépôts de
plainte donc au final on se demande bas
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire et ça a
toujours pas bougé rien rien n'a été
fait alors c'est là qu'on tu vois que
pour toi digard aucune issue tu penses
au pire tu penses à mettre fin à ses
jours oui je les pensais qu est ce que
tu t'es dit je me suis dit que au final
elle avait peut-être raison que c'était
peut-être mieux si j'étais plus là et
même au collège
au final je me suis peut-être mieux
parce que c'est peut-être de ma faute
qu'est ce que tu voulais faire
je voulais en finir mais quelle manière
tu avais penses tu t'es dit je veux
faire quoi je sais pas j ai pas pensé je
voulais je voulais juste en finir temps
à parler à quelqu'un la firme hier du
collège mais elle périodiquement la
fermière je lui avais je lui ai raconté
ce qui se passe est attendue et elle m'a
répondu la même chose que pratiquement
tout le monde au collège c'est des
histoires de gamins d'accord tu lui as
dit jouer je vais me mettre fin à mes
jours non elle a vu les scarifications
et elle n'a pas mis ça sur le dos du
joueur seulement à la met ça sur le dos
au final elle disait bas c'était à la
maison ça se passe pas bien alors que
tout se passait bien c'est juste que
j'étais pas bien chez moi parce que mon
comportement avait changé je me défoule
et chez moi bien sûr et pas me défouler
au collège était devenue insupportable à
la maison et en fait que tu te manger
sur sur tes parents ta famille parce que
je pouvais pas le faire au collège c'est
ça oui c'est que ça tu réussissais quand
même à travailler chez toi à
faire tes devoirs ou à suivre les cours
ou pas du tout pas trop pas trop non
donc les résultats étaient des mauvais
rien ça va moyen d'arriver à t'en sortir
commence à stagner à stagner
aujourd'hui c'est pour
ces biens qui monsieur ministre soit là
tant des moutons histoire
aujourd'hui tu es au lycée oui
comment ça se passe ça se passe bien
tout ça c'est derrière toi pas trop bas
pas seulement parce que ça continue
encore à venir les réseaux sur les
réseaux oui il y en a surtout l'une
d'entre elles qui parle encore de moi
qui m'insultent et c'est pour ça comme
je les dis avant que j'ai arrêté de
sortir dehors parce que sinon ce ça
aurait encore empirer
parce que la dernière fois que je suis
sorti dehors ça remonte à quelques mois
peut-être six sept mois et on m'a
insulté on m'a menacé donc c'est pour ça
que j'ai arrêté de sortir et ça continue
sur les réseaux donc c'est insupportable